Hey youtubers, It’s charlie, welcome to
part 2 of my many part game of thrones season
4 preview.
I’d like to say it’s going to be three
parts, but I could talk all year about a song
of ice and fire, so we’ll see.
In case you didn’t see my part 1 video I’m
separating each of these previews by geographic
region relatively.
A lot of people wander.
This video will cover all the characters in
the north and around the wall including Arya
who is said wanderer.
There will be some spoilers, but I’ll try
to warn you before in case you want to just
mute the audio for a sec.
In which case you’ll have to wait till next
January to find out what’s going on, so
I would advise watching the whole video so
we can geek out on Game of Thrones together.
It’s way more fun with other people.
Shall we begin!
So let’s start with the starks, primarily
Jon Snow.
If you look carefully, you’ll see in the
opening credits Kit Harington is actually
featured as one of the bigger main cast members.
He is a major character in the books, but
I feel like the show gives some actors more
lines and scenes based on who the producers
consider to be the most important.
And if season 3 was big for Jon Snow, then
season 4 will be so much bigger.
Remember that after the finale he had just
made it back to the night’s watch after
going through what I’m calling a pretty
normal ‘wildling breakup’.
Think of that conversation, look man I either
we talk all night about our relationship and
were we’re going as a couple, or I can shoot
you with three arrows....Thinks about it for
a minute...I’ll take the arrows.
That Jon Snow, not much for small talk.
Here’s where we start to get into spoiler
territory.
I’ll try to be as vague as possible for
anyone who likes to find out via internet
sleuthing or reading the books.
Jon Snow doesn’t move around much as a character,
not nearly as much as Arya, so he’s going
to be spending all of season 4 back with the
Night’s Watch.
There aren’t going to be a lot of new characters
at the Wall.
We’ll see one character from season 2 come
back, his name is Janos Slynt and he was the
person Tyrion fired as head of the gold cloaks
in kings landing before the battle of blackwater
bay.
Remember he made Bronn the leader of the gold
cloaks before Tywin came back at the end of
that season.
Since nobody knew about Jon’s secret mission
to infiltrate the wildlings you can imagine
the shit he’s going to be taking since everyone
thinks he was a traitor.
I won’t say specifically what happens, but
the night’s watch itself goes through some
changes just as a big battle is coming.
Which leads me back to the wildlings.
Remember they were in the middle of their
march on the night’s watch.
There’s actually a new character called
The Magnar of thenn.
He’s just another general in the wildling
army like Tormund Giant’s Bane.
The producers actually gave a lot of the book
scenes the magnar had to tormund in season
3 to cut down on the number of new cast members.
That problem is only going to get worse, they’ve
already cut out a lot of subplots from the
first half of book 3, now that we’re moving
into the second part and parts of book 4,
we’re going to see fewer and fewer book
characters.
That’s not necessarily a bad thing, but
for anyone keeping track, let’s just say
we’ll only be getting two or three battles
if that, and that includes Dany in Mereen.
I’ll talk about her in another preview video,
but let’s talk about Arya.
She was one of my favorite characters in season
3.
Arya spends most of her time wandering, but
because the show moves so quickly I think
we’ll get some really good arya action in
the first two episodes.
Think of Arya and the hound in the first couple
of episodes as being like a little sister
and a big daddy from bioshock.
You want to stay as far away from them as
possible.
Her other nickname now is stabby mcgee.
(stabbing motion).
If you remember the shot of arya with her
valar morghulis coin, that storyline will
move forward and I think we’ll get to see
her use it near the end of the season.
Definitely before episode 9.
Someone in the comments asked me about her
valyrian steel blade Needle, she does get
it back.
I won’t say how, but it’s going to be
awesome.
Don’t you just feel like her scenes make
you want to laugh, but because they’re so
dark or she’s so nuts you feel awful every
time you do.
I think it’s just because she looks so young,
it’s so unexpected to see such a little
girl act the way she does and speak with so
much conviction.
In the books she’s supposed to be about
13 years old.
Ygritte is still a part of the story, you
remember she had that heartbreaking scene
with Jon Snow at the end of season 3.
Remember what she said to him before they
climbed the wall.
“Don’t ever betray me...”
Let me know in the comments what you think
she’s going to do when she sees Jon Snow
again.
Let’s just say it’s not like running into
your ex-girlfriend in a movie theater.
waaay more awkward.
Those wildling women, gotta be careful, yikes.
I’m going to save any of the other supporting
characters for another video, but send me
your questions and I’ll try to include them
in the next video.
Be sure to subscribe to get my part 3 video.
I’ll be posting it on Monday, it will cover
Dany and the characters in the east.
In case you haven’t seen it yet you can
click here to watch part 1, it covers king’s
landing.
and you can click here to watch my game of
thrones father’s day video.
It’s all about the best worst dad’s on
game of thrones.
Thanks for watching, high fives for season
4!